tú
[Música]
generalmente cuando estudiamos el pasado
de los pueblos hacemos referencia y
estamos involucrando nos con uno de los
conocimientos que intencionalmente en
países como el nuestro han sido
discriminados y han sido eliminados de
los procesos educativos serios que
pretenden transformar vidas
hablar del significado del pasado de los
pueblos es evocar algo que es
fundamental para ese poder humano para
el más puro de los poderes humanos y es
el poder del conocimiento el poder que
nos pueden brindar el concierto de las
ciencias sociales el concierto de los
conocimientos humanistas y dentro de
ellos uno que es vital y que ha sido un
discurso presente en las culturas del
mundo estoy refiriéndome a la ciencia
histórica hablar de la ciencia histórica
y tratar de convencer a todo ser humano
de que el conocimiento de su pasado es
vital para poder transformar vidas es
fundamental en espacios académicos pero
también en espacios y en recintos
culturales hoy traigo para ustedes una
propuesta y una propuesta que ha sido y
ha dado significado también a mi vida
académica una propuesta por medio de la
cual quiero hacerles reflexionar sobre
lo que esto significa y es el estudio de
la historia como ciencia sin duda alguna
sin duda alguna todos los que estamos
acá hemos experimentado desde nuestras
aulas parvularias hasta llegar a la
universidad
ese conocimiento que se nos ha dicho que
se llama historia pero que muy pocas
veces muy pocas veces se nos ha dicho
que es una ciencia y como tal también
esa ciencia se construye y se
reconstruye por científicos sociales a
los cuales se les ha denominado hoy los
historiadores esos historiadores que en
el pasado fueron historiógrafos fueron
aquellos eruditos que con su pluma que
con su buen sentido y que con su
capacidad artística y su gran memoria
podían registrar los hechos
esos eruditos que se fueron que fueron
evolucionando y cambiando en las
distintas épocas y que su legado llega
hoy a nosotros a través de su obra de
sus libros de su pensamiento de su
propuesta y del registro de esos
acontecimientos que justamente se
convierten en importantes porque nos dan
las luces de cómo fue ese pasado
esa historia de la cual habló también ha
sido transformada a través del tiempo
todos también hemos experimentado como
aquellos profesores desde la escuela
primaria hacían referencia que el
concepto de historia era un arte que la
historia era un arte que registraba esos
hechos que se convertían en hechos
importantes para el conocimiento de todo
ser humano
y ese concepto de historia en ese
transcurrir del tiempo ha ido cambiando
hoy de la historia que quiero
convencerlos y hablarles es de esas
historias científicas que no sólo ve
hacia atrás que no sólo ve el pasado de
los pueblos en retrospectiva sino que
encuentra una utilidad práctica y una
utilidad altamente humana cuando nos
sitúa a todos en un tiempo histórico
presente
los que estamos hoy acá estamos viviendo
y estamos conviviendo
una plática una exposición que nos hace
reflexionar desde lo que hoy somos como
sociedad
desde lo que hoy estamos viviendo con
nuestras virtudes con nuestras
posibilidades y con nuestras
limitaciones pero esa historia que hoy
estamos viviendo y que es historia viva
e historia del presente por supuesto que
tiene un pasado un pasado que ha dado
las causas y las raíces que hoy nos
explica
como sociedad que hoy nos explica en
esos múltiples componentes que hoy nos
explica como un pueblo con posibilidades
y con precariedad es y que hoy nos
explica desde el elemento biológico
hasta el elemento altamente cultural
esa historia de la cual hoy estoy
hablando es también una historia que no
sólo incorpora esa reflexión profunda
del pasado de los pueblos
también incorpora y cobra ese sentido y
significado cuando planteamos las pautas
de un desarrollo a futuro y ahí
encontramos en esas tres grandes
categorías temporales encontramos la
definición de eso que ha sido una de mis
pasiones en la vida el conocimiento de
la ciencia histórica
quiero también comentarles que si bien
es cierto la historia la hemos estudiado
a través de personajes de batallas
muchas veces de héroes también pocas
veces la hemos cuestionado en función a
quién o quiénes han hecho esa
interpretación de la historia que hoy
podemos cuestionar que ayer podíamos
cuestionar y que podemos seguir
cuestionando y en ese sentido vamos a
percibir que los personajes por sí solos
son incapaces de generar procesos
históricos un personaje se convierta en
un personaje justamente cuando lo
ubicamos en su escenario con otros
sujetos sociales que están haciendo
posible su existencia real
pero los historiadores cuestionamos ese
tipo de historia que la reconstruye no
la construyen los personajes que se
suceden unos a otros y estamos en una
constante revisión y también en una
constante revisión que nos da una
capacidad de duda
y por supuesto esa capacidad de duda nos
da también la posibilidad de poder
cuestionar si esa historia que nos han
presentado los libros tradicionalmente
es una historia real y ahí entramos
entramos en uno en uno de los ejercicios
académicos más importantes pero también
más satisfactorios el pensar dudar
reflexionar contradecir y volver a
pensar y repensar si eso que hemos
estudiado si esos personajes si esa
estructura del tiempo que hemos
aprendido es realmente real valga la
redundancia
si es realmente objetiva ife y vean qué
importante es esto porque no creer al
cien por ciento lo que dicen los libros
y las verdades planteadas en los libros
nos da una capacidad de cuestionar
y esa capacidad de dudar y de cuestionar
es uno de los motores más importantes
para generar conocimiento científico
conocimientos absolutos
en ciencias sociales y en ciencias
naturales no pueden no pueden haber
verdades múltiples en ciencias sociales
no pueden haber y ahí cuestionamos dos
cosas el hecho que realmente ha sucedido
y como la capacidad del historiador
trata de recuperar este hecho para darlo
y socializarlo hacia los demás y hemos
descubierto algo fundamental
lo que decía la historia no la hacen
solo los personajes la historia la hacen
los pueblos enteros los conglomerados y
vamos a encontrar en ese recorrido de
los episodios de las edades y de los
períodos históricos una historia que
también hay que reflexionar la desde los
marcos de los dramatismos
y desde los marcos también de las peores
tragedias humanas la historia también ha
sido eso ha sido drama y ha sido
tragedia y específicamente en el caso de
nuestra sociedad ese drama y esa
tragedia han sido una de las constantes
más permeables en esa línea del tiempo
histórico no del tiempo biológico hablo
del tiempo histórico el tiempo
construido el tiempo que se ha armado en
base a la experiencia humana
y ese concepto de historia que hoy
comparto con ustedes y que les propongo
como una forma distinta de pensar nos a
sí mismos en lo individual y en lo
colectivo esa propuesta que hoy traigo
para todos ustedes es a esa propuesta
que la historia al ser asumida también
nos da la posibilidad de ser seres
transformadores un conocimiento es una
facultad humana y un conocimiento que se
adquiere por sí mismo y se queda en una
humanidad sin darse a los demás no
tienen ningún sentido esas academias que
deambulan con muchos libros esos
estudiantes y esos profesores que se
ufanan de leer tanto pero que su
expresión de vida
no lo demuestra porque esos
conocimientos esas dos categorías que el
pueblo griego acuñó como el educar y el
exvocero están llenando nos ese vacío de
conocimientos que como seres humanos
tenemos pero que somos muchas veces
incapaces de traducir en acciones y en
actitudes de vida una vida armoniosa una
vida con sabiduría implica poner poner
en práctica dentro de nuestra propia
dinámica diaria esos conocimientos
percibidos en ámbitos académicos libros
doctorales tesis post doctorales muy
bien muy exitosas pero eso debe de
traducirse en la propia condición humana
y cuando hablamos de las ciencias
sociales y de una ciencia tan vigorosa y
tan vital como la historia no puedo
concebir alumnos profesores
vivan al margen de las precariedades de
todo un pueblo que no sean sensibles
ante el dolor y el sufrimiento que no
puedan pensar en su felicidad personal y
particular sin concebir lo que está
aconteciendo en sus contextos y en sus
entornos una ciencia histórica que nos
conmueva una ciencia histórica que como
decía la escuela historiográfica de los
grandes críticos que se transforma en la
escuela del criticismo hay que hacer un
alto hay que hacer un alto para pensar
ese concepto y hacer una reflexión
profunda de lo que significa desde la
postura científica epistemológica eso
que las ciencias sociales hemos
denominado una historia trascendente eso
que las ciencias sociales denominan el
provocar mentes críticas que transformen
sus entornos
eso que las ciencias sociales evocan
como algo que es intrínseco a la
coherencia del ser humano y a su propia
vivencia por lo tanto la historia no es
un recorrido de episodios
la historia no es una secuencia de
períodos que se suceden y que estan
yuxtapuestos unos con otros la historia
tiene un significado y la historia tiene
un sentido un sentido porque la historia
busca la verdad porque busca basada en
en esa razón de ser
esa verdad que tiende a ser también una
verdad artística una verdad poética no
una verdad poética en el sentido
estricto de lo lírico sino una verdad
poética que se acerque a lo filosófico
porque en una historia que se acerca a
lo filosófico a lo poético y a lo
artístico podemos encontrar la esperanza
de los pueblos la resistencia de los
pueblos que hoy más que nunca se unen y
unen esfuerzos en función de la defensa
de sus intereses colectivos que no
desvirtúa procesos por eso tres
categorías siempre han permanecido en el
concepto de la historia
la categoría del tiempo representada
desde los griegos y en épocas
posteriores y aún más atrás con los
egipcios y la mesopotamia con un reloj
representada iconográficamente como una
figura ancestral anciana la figura del
tiempo la figura de cronos la figura de
ese dios que registra a través de la
temporalidad
por supuesto la historia registrando los
procesos de esos acontecimientos que
conmueven a la vida hacia los seres
humanos que cuestiona hoy también esos
bloques de poder que en la historia
inmediata estamos viviendo esos bloques
que se aglomeran sobre todo bajo
parámetros que deshumanizan al ser
humano hoy hablo de esa historia que en
su tercer elemento evoca siempre a la
verdad una historia que conmueve y
sensibiliza una historia que nos mueve
el tapete que nos hace ser mentes
críticas transformativas una historia
que promueven todos aquellos que le
estudian a conciencia una mente que nos
posibilita sentir el dolor sentir el
drama sentir la alegría y sobre todo
tener la esperanza en los pueblos porque
los pueblos se resisten porque los
pueblos son los sujetos protagónicos de
una historia verdad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i